one little girl from zimbabwe she asked
um does god have a wife
and some of the
young people would say i don't think god
needs a wife he's got it all
you know
what's funny about that is god does have
a wife yes it's the church that's right
it's bright yes
he speaks about it yes
if you had just one question to ask god
what would it be
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness
hey everybody welcome to led live we've
got a very exciting show for you today
because it's not every day that you get
to sit next to a kgb agent
from russia
we would like to thank all of you who
support this ministry through your
donations and by buying merch from
lightware.shop we cannot do this without
you and if you send in your pictures we
will put you on the show
when you talk to this guy sounds like
he's a kgb agent some world travelers
and uh you know i don't know about you
guys but uh i i i there's certain parts
of traveling that i really enjoy
and uh
i guess that wasn't always the case with
you guys oh by the way this is dimitri
and grace
and uh they have a really unique
ministry that they're going to tell us
about today but they travel around the
world how many countries have you been
in
i think the last count around 54 or so
54 countries that's have you been on all
seven continents yes
okay that's pretty that's an amazing
feat because
that's pretty good i i don't even know
i've never sat down and actually counted
them have you yeah yeah i think i got to
the 20s 20s that's impressive but my
goal is to reach all seven continents by
30. we'll see if that happens
yes i was made in russia born and grew
up in saint petersburg the second
biggest city in russia
so exactly where the communist soviet
revolution took place
so it's very alive did you watch that
take place no no no okay
oh a little younger
yeah maybe
it's a rich history in this city
yes and of course
under the red flag you know pretty much
people like me had very little hope to
see
you know other countries especially
capitalist countries you know free
countries you probably can go to cuba or
like some you know
you some other community
yeah so anyway so and for for some
reason
god gave me like
desire even before i knew god you know i
wanted to see the world you know i want
to see not just the world just at least
one or two countries we have a neighbor
good neighbor finland
if i can go to finland or sweden next
neighbor yeah it will be a
you know
life ambition
so you didn't believe
well in my
soviet school systems you know they made
sure to
brainwash that out yes yes religious
for your mind stay away from religion
and when we of course learn the
medieval
dark ages history it's convincing
you don't need god
you know and russia went to space of
course you know the space program
so and there was a talk that when
russian went to space there was no god
on the cloud just like
wow
your rocket blew up which is what i
remember the history right and that's
what allowed us to actually send a
rocket up was that uh you guys had
actually beat the us by miles in the
technology
but it set you back because of the
explosion of the rocket that's i think
that's what i remember
well yes
yes so so you you're you know you said
you were part of the military as well
yes every
man you know we had a mandatory military
service and when you turn 18 or 19
depends on you if you're finishing your
degree
so they will allow you to go one year
later so that was me so i went when when
i was 19 years old wow so soviet navy
forest of russia yes i was shipped there
but unlike to serve serving on the navy
vessel or submarine i was on the coast
guard you know like a naval base so i
served two years
in two weeks
did that help you achieve your
your life ambition to see another
country or did you stay in russia i
stayed in
in fact you know and after military
service was finished there was a
military office i believe like secret
service one of those kgb officers who
stuck of papers you know fold the
serious look
so they brought us a paper to sign up
here i'm not allowed to go abroad for
five years wow yeah so
i'm gonna keep that promise well no
because the soviet union collapsed
so the soviet union was that's what i
committed but that's what i signed but
there was no more soviet union that time
so wow so i was
anyway so after your military how did
you how did you then start to begin to
travel
well where did this come into play so it
was uh
you know what they call it the carrot
yes before the horse or the donkey so
they told me if i enrolled i was a
carpenter by trade
like jesus
so anyway i was a carpenter and they
told us if i go to on the docks to to
work as a carpenter i will have a chance
probably to go to cuba and some other
countries
you know as a carpenter on the
vessel
so and that's what i
enrolled but
soon i realized it was just
to get me to to work hard
eight nine hours a day
for probably earning 30 dollars a month
is that just because of the communism no
the economy crashed
we had completely recession i mean
the dollar was close to ruble on the
black market probably you can buy
three dollars one room i mean three
rubles one dollar wow but in the time
when i was uh after soviet union
7 000 rubles one dollar and inflation
was so
going quick down that the food stores
was closed for a while because they
don't want to sell you you know food
because the next day the price will be
different
so they hold on to it
maybe the next day they'll make twice as
much money oh yeah that's just a major
problem so and when
i was almost depressed you know yeah in
a way because all my kind of dreams are
collapsing and one day i went to the
sailboat club and i was just standing
there and watching sailboats going
back and forth and i'm kind of
thinking like wow they probably go to
finland you know and some other
countries you know
you know and there was as i was looking
on the sailboat the captain like you
want to come in you want to join us they
were just about to go to see to go in
the gulf of finland
so and that was life-changing for me
because uh they liked me right away and
i was for my navy yeah yeah so i didn't
i was not afraid of water and swimming
and so on and was enthusiastic and a
carpenter i can fix stuff on the boat
man so the captain like hey you want to
be a crew member you know we go abroad
once a year you know the for racing you
know baltic traditional sailing yeah
so that was life-changing because
i think uh
the year later i went to sweden yeah so
what was that like did you see finland
from the
no no no actually we went to sweden oh
you were just playing
so the first time you rounded the corner
and saw a foreign land
like
that was
different world i mean that was i mean
i'm
serious the best description the best
description captain's wife was in tears
she cried and cried because she never
seen it either no but she was just she
cried because of such a contrast you
know of our you know she grew up also
also in the soviet union and you know
but she's seen this
free society you know the people like
happy 18 19 years old you know going to
college already live separately from
parents
you know it's just like
you know no fear everything is clean and
organized
you've been in sweden you know i have
been this video yes
so that was
and the best way to describe she was in
tears she cried and cried like why why
why our country cannot be like this
so you got the travel bug right there
and bit with it
now where did you two meet then
oh wow that's quite a jump
but uh
he actually was um
had a
quite an experience
learning about god there right oh yeah
let's get to that before you guys
actually met yeah
that's kind of what led to all this tell
us like what was that moment that you
actually came to an understanding or
belief in god
well
after my trip to sweden
you know
it was not very ambitious for me to
continue to work as a carpenter
so and my friend told me hey they have a
summer
part-time job as a busboy and a
five-star hotel
so and i learned some english a little
bit you know kind of broken english you
know
i don't consider it i knew english
so but somewhat i was better than others
in a way so and i had a little
confidence to go and apply for a job
so and uh because i went to sweden in
the five-star hotel hotel europe and
saint petersburg was that time
joint venture with sweden and russia
so and i thought maybe because i went to
sweden they might hire me
i was still working as a carpenter and i
was hired part-time to do busboy
and boy i was happy it was free food
i was constantly i was
hungry yeah you know so and as of course
i got some
little income but the tips
yeah so once in a while the waitress got
sick or something or you know and
can you serve the table i served the
table i got
a dollar here and five dollar
as a part-time for few hours i made more
than one month
so and of course i was so happy i was
constantly trying to learn english
that's why i enrolled in the english
courses with american teachers wow they
introduced me to christ
so
did it come up in the conversation
during the teaching moments no it was
regular courses and kind of in the
evening
what they did they invited us for friday
night fellowship
very informal just get to know each
other and it was
not the bible studies nothing like this
but
open conversation debates bring your
views and we bring our views wow so you
know and it was
i liked it it was like very informal so
you get to know teachers
so and then we realized they were like
strong believers and what kind of the
first
impressed me
those
with the high education
nurses
you know there was one biologist san
jose university biology major scientist
believe in the bible
another one was from san jose you know
state university two years at pvc but
san jose he graduated in environmental
science wow you know very smart
intelligent man bruce wow you know so he
believed in god so yeah and they were
all a very balanced and you know nice
people to be around wow so that was
first challenge how can you become be a
christian with a scientific background
see sometimes it's not always just the
knowledge sometimes yeah it's just the
interactions that we actually have with
people that speak more than more than
words right you know you've seen them
and you're going hey wait what's what's
unique about these people yes and my
spiritual journey started pretty much
from this group when i missed this group
i went you know on a sailboat and
decided like ah forget this friday night
meeting i would rather
you know have a party you know after you
know race or after
going on a sailboat we had their you
know drink and
felt but i missed the you know our
friday night actually
meetings so i thought it was more
meaningful to be there then next day
have a headache
and regret what's happening how long did
that go on before you really started
doing bible study well it's been
probably at least a year all right yeah
and what's happened interesting because
i
the my life in soviet union left me
impression it was a big you know
this deception right you know the whole
system they were promising the bright
future you know and happy people and it
was totally opposite oppressed people
and crushed economy and and of course
more and more corruption of the previous
leaders was coming out in the news
so
and
everything was what was prohibited in
soviet union now i it got my attention
you know and of course one of them is
you know bibles and religions
so that so i'm gonna check it out
so and another thing was uh
he was lending me my teacher lending me
a book
would you like to read english classics
so
what's the name of it pilgrim's progress
it was prohibited during soviet union
times to read it
oh he gave me the book
i would like to read it and what he did
he lend it to me probably if he would
give me for free it was in russian
language you know old print
if he would probably give it to me as a
free book i would put it on the shelf
someday i will read but he lend it to me
and i said i'm obligated to read yeah so
yeah actually witnessing school you know
it's a built-in phone
but i want it back
so but listen what's happened next i
came home i opened boy this is christian
stuff
that's kind of like religious i don't
really want to read my first impression
you know but then okay that's all pre
and printed and various time and plus my
teacher probably will ask how do you
like it you know what did you read this
chapter and i should read it very
quickly at least i said i read it
so and as i start reading guess what
holy spirit worked on me because i start
recognizing like oh that's my teacher
that's my family that's me
over there
you know it's really made me impression
so when i was
giving him back thank you bruce it was a
really good book
did you like it and as a matter of fact
yes you can keep it
oh thank you
so so before i read the bible god spoke
to me through english classic by john
bunyan if you never read it please read
it wow yeah
i remember right i think he wrote that
in prison yes
yes
so yeah it spoke to me i recognized i
was in the city of destruction yes i
recognized me as a you know wretched
lost
you know and
it spoke to me yes wow wow
so so now that you kind of have this
newfound faith
how did you even get in touch in america
or how did this connection happen here
well
so pretty much
as i start
you know accepting christ and
start reading the bible there was a
battle in my soul because it's like
all my previous views it was crushing
you know yeah and i was pretty skeptical
kind of like
thomas
you know so i just decided i was renting
the room it was my english teacher he
invited me would you like to be my like
roommate
you know so and i read this russian
bible printed in finland and they
smuggle bibles from finland to russia
and soviet days
so and it's hard to believe all this
miracle raising the dead you know
creation stories you know it's just
unbelievable resurrection you know the
christ is the life really you know
because all i've seen is russian
orthodox crosses with the you know
christ crucified and that was it
yeah so and then simple prayer if you
never prayed this prayer please pray
god if you're real prove it to me
god if the bible is truth please let me
know prove it to me let me help my
unbelief wow you know so and from that
time
you know god gave me dreams you know
you know about my former girlfriend and
nightmare so it was the warning sign
you know so when she broke up with
everything
so okay and then my values start
changing wow yeah so what i did before i
had no more joy yeah you know so he
started giving me like new values new
new desires
so and i start realizing that even
though i cannot touch god but he is real
because i see changes in my life amen
and so that's
one of the journey and to make the story
short i was studying in college you know
hotel management and tourism
so i was promoted a few times in a
five-star hotel
it was uh
you served ted turner okay
when i was a head waiter yes there was a
goodwill games kind of like olympics and
ted turner with jane fonda as a wife
those days yeah and a blondie kid
so they were sponsors so and they
hey yeah they came to russia and they
asked me to serve him you know
wow to turn and jimmy carter came with a
mission you know to help orphanages in
russia and so the boss called me dmitry
you're going to serve mr president and
remember you can screwed up with food
and order but never remember the title
don't call him mister or so mr president
mr president that's more important than
anything else
if josh is burnt mr president i'm sorry
yes
exactly so i remember you know coming to
jimmy carter and mr president what would
you like to drink
sparkling water and that was it
mr president can i take away your plate
and that was it
and i know some fellow americans you
know they run oh mr president let me
shake your hand it's a pleasure to meet
you right in russia
so this sounded like a pretty nice hotel
i mean what happened to that career
so yes i was
planning to make a career in hotel
management that's why i was taking the
college classes in baltic college of
tourism
so to become a hotel management hotel
and tourism manager
so and
at the same time i'm learning the bible
truth
and i found out that
god is asking me to keep the saturday
sabbath holy wow you know and that was a
dilemma because
in the hotel settings yeah saturdays are
the busiest days it's all the functions
and birthdays and you know it's just the
natural flow of people in the
restaurants and hotel
another dilemma was the some of the
final exams in my college it was on
saturday wow so and i start
facing like a real personal spiritual
struggle is it what's more important in
my life
my career or even freedom to travel in
the future or garden in the bible and
what he's asking for me
so so
how much of the bible have you read
that's one question i have and
was that something you discovered
through study with other people or just
completely on your own you're reading
and you're like oh this is here well the
friday night's gatherings was actually
okay that's where you started to learn
that yes you can ask questions you know
and of course the the at the end there
was optional always
to watch the movie you know and to have
we have translators my english was not
that good so we had some russians who
pretty much was close to be fluent in
english so
and when the american teacher spoke and
answered the questions
so it just um
one more thing i should tell you though
was
what they presented to me is
that there was a sabbath keeping in
ancient russia wow yes
so so it was in because i was like why
not sunday even even in the russian
bible it was not the lord's day in in
the uh revelation 1 10
you know in the lord's day i was you
know
the john is writing
so the russian bible is sunday you know
resurrection day
so sorry and it's like
excuse me what about you know sundays
and the whole christian world is you
know keeping sunday holy where did you
get this saturday idea you know so what
translation was that i'm curious
i don't know how to say it in english
because my understanding is that later
like
was it the 90s
maybe late 80s early 90s there was
another translation
that was
developed that became pretty well
widespread
and i don't think it would have had i
think it would have gone back to you
know in the united states well there was
a several russian bibles original was
ancient bibles was lord's day there was
no changes okay so then there was
somewhere maybe 1800s mid-1800s i don't
remember but this uh another you know
american teacher ivan
he had
a deep in-depth research on
sabbath-keeping in russia so and as he
was presenting this material i was like
wow the first christians in russia
actually kept saturday sabbath holy
according to the bible
you know and of course
many
you know
other facts i learned and i was under
conviction so it is
it's not the sunday it is saturday
seventh day to keep it holy
so i was to make the story short i came
to my boss
can i work on sundays instead of
saturdays
on a regular basis uh i i won't be able
to
you know to come on saturdays from now
on yeah friday night to saturday
yeah the two busiest times of a hotel
period yes exactly
well i was a good worker so it was not
much questions you know like
i suppose you can you know
so so and
so
it was good until the colleagues
start being jealous how come he's so
special you know every saturday every
busy
day you know
so there was a pressure on
manager to put me back on a regular
schedule
but
the busier days mean more people and
likely you get more tips
yes so
i don't know why they didn't complain
about that
you
know because once in a while saturdays
involve some
movie theaters or events you know they
they
they don't want to do it on the right
something happened i mean probably you
know devil stirred them up
you know
in any way there was
and because of unemployment in russia
many people were there was a big pile of
applications for my position
you know they didn't have to keep me and
i accommodate accommodate me
you know but for a while it was okay
until the colleagues become you know
complaining and more pressure on the
manager
and instead of going with in trouble
with the colleagues and explaining he
just put me back on the schedule
and i thought lord what should i do
again again it's a dilemma
and i said well i will honor god and
there is a promise you own a god he will
own you back that's right and somehow in
my mind i thought i'll just don't come
on saturday come on sunday and
apologize and do some extra work
for them and
somehow he will be in control of it
but instead so i came to
my work
on sunday
they were furious they were mad
angry
red faces you know screaming at me
you know what was the reason why i
didn't come to work because somebody
else couldn't come for another health
issue or something so it was a bad day
for them
so and somehow i realized uh where where
was god
why he didn't make it smooth right yeah
smooth transitions some kind of
sometimes he doesn't yeah so anyway the
manager told me you know
you know
you can keep your sabbath but you're
fired wow so that means
i don't have any income
i don't have i cannot pay for my college
degree education and to make this
story worse it was in my college like
final exam on saturday i come to the gym
i'm sorry i cannot come for the final
exam on saturday
are you sick you have any health issues
no ma'am
some issues in your family is in your
something happening in your family no
ma'am what
can't be
so important as for you to miss the exam
it's my conviction because i would like
to own a god it's my
you know i i won't be able to do it on
saturday
are you studying hotel management and
you want your saturdays on
you know this kind of talk and then i
remember didn't
looked at my face look at my eyes i
cannot guarantee you graduate wow
so god closed all those doors yes i mean
my girlfriend is leaving me i'm not a
cool guy anymore
so it's just like god where are you what
what's happening
no so that was
one of the experience so what made you
stay i mean all this is happening and
it's because of this root thing of your
values and your faith changing yeah what
made you think that was worth it well
goddess was speaking to me in my
conscience you know
you have now your new values
and and
just trust me you know the
target yeah and and what i'm based on
reading in the bible i read about
martyrs
and i was in my 20s you know in all my
life dreams in korean travel in
relationship to find someone special who
wants that kind of guy you know to date
extreme thinking you know you know it's
kind of like
i thought
his god is calling me to be a martyr to
suffer you know
life maybe you know being homeless with
no degree no job i don't know
so but
the general manager of the hotel when he
heard what happened
he called my you know direct manager
and told him not told him he actually
screamed
he says you have no right to treat him
like this you promise him he can have
such a dissolve keep your promise you
know you cannot fight him he's going
back wow
and of course
i was not anymore in a honorable
position i was back to be a busboy on a
you know buffet in a breakfast buffet
so and
cleaning the glasses wine glasses you
know at the end of the shift part-time
wow so and then going from serving the
president
right yeah i was a little manager i
trained the waiters and one particular
waitress coming to get her
recommendation to go to america ymca and
she's not even a christian you know ymca
yeah she's an atheist and she's applying
to go to the christian organization to
be in the summer christian summer camp
wow so and she
sees me cleaning the glasses oh mr
dmitry what's happened to you
a long story
you know then she just
why don't you go to america you know why
don't you apply to go ymca you know like
what you know yeah
what it takes we just get recommendation
from your job from your college
you know you just write your english is
okay you know
you know so i improved my english
wow so and
i thought there is no way plus it takes
800 plus dollars close to 900 for the
ticket and
i was saving for my college so it's like
no way
so i told you that i don't think it's
really realistic
she comes next day
what are you losing why don't you go to
america you know
why don't you try just apply
and then
something happened because it's i i
almost heard the voice
why don't you try you know what you're
losing and maybe god is speaking
wow
i read the story god can speak through
the donkey right he can speak through
atheist girl who is trying to con why
don't you go why didn't you know maybe
after america they will respect you four
months you know you can improve your
english you know so and i thought
recommendation from my job they tried to
fire me
recommendation from my college the dean
told me no guarantee i graduated because
of the issues
those are the situations that god likes
but it's like impossible because that's
when he's gonna like make it happen and
you can't take the credit for that yeah
you thought you were fired too yeah
well i knew my days are numbered
in a hotel so
so anyway so i applied and everything is
worked out
technically miraculously because of the
time limit you know i just you know the
of course manager didn't want to write
me a recommendation so
i came to my former colleague a head
waiter do you mind to write
recommendation for me to go to ymca who
am i yeah i'm nobody i'm not even you
know
so they don't consider it headway to the
manager you know technically
you know
i said well i have no choice if you
don't write i don't i will lose a chance
you know my english is so bad you know
you're right i signed
i was the manager at the five star hotel
i served the president
no no
i'm
not that way
so i came to my
english teacher do you mind to write me
a recommendation you know to help me of
course and my former teachers for my you
know
you know good and faithful and true
so they did you know the manager signed
you know they did all their own
recommendation and everything and
so then of course the money delimited by
the ticket and and of course anyway to
make the story short
i ended up in new york city
jfk in 1997 in june wow tired because it
was a long day from flying from the west
to the i mean from the east to the west
to
the same day
[Laughter]
so where did you come into the picture
well we actually met at an airport
not jfk though no
but uh
yeah
i was actually born in america and so i
was born in this land of freedom and
i had a passport and whatnot but i never
really
used it except to go back to japan
because my parents
they became christian in japan wow and
both of them
was through media like uh one
my father
was given this book called steps to
christ and it was in japanese language
when he was in the army
and that's how he learned about christ
and and he became a christian on his own
out of his whole family he's the only
one and my mother too um she listened to
this broadcast called voice of prophecy
and
in japanese and that's how she came into
the to the faith and
they realized
they couldn't raise a family in japan
because
there was mandatory school on saturdays
and they felt convicted that
the all the board exams for all the
professional um
uh careers are also on saturday and the
government would not change it
because they would say it's not fair to
other people you could have advanced
knowledge or whatnot
so
they moved to america and i was um
deposited on american soil
i was actually made in japan my mother
was pregnant
and
had morning sickness on the
in hawaii and uh wow so um i'm a freedom
loving american
but
when we met at the airport it was
actually um
at the college that he attended yeah
because um we have
mutual aviation major friends who had
friday night vespers um a little bible
study on friday nights that we'd all get
together and
and that's how we met
but we felt it was very providential
because we both had this yearning to go
back to our
um or to other countries and and share
this hope and gospel to other people
because
we felt like
you know we
were so blessed with god's presence in
our lives so from the beginning we we
would
recognize that we were not going to just
stay put we were going to go out this
was a conversation you guys were having
early on in the beginning let's go out
and let's share what we've learned
with the world
yeah i think even that first night at
the airport we were already talking
about what we wanted to do mission wise
to
serve god
in different countries
and
it's interesting because even at our
wedding
instead of rice you know when people
throw rice
we had people take paper origami and uh
make paper airplanes for us and send us
off
because we said it's actually really
super clever
we met at an airport and we figured we'd
see many more airports and
then you get to see everybody's airplane
making skills
well talking about the bible truth when
i read genesis you know you start from
the beginning right genesis 2 18 it was
not good for men to be alone i believe
it amen
there is a truth in the bible
you take the bible
but so you guys get married and then all
of a sudden did you immediately start
traveling
uh not immediately we we spent some time
at a lifestyle center and worked for
them and then
we had the call to go to guam and
micronesia
and i worked as a physical therapist at
the clinic and he was in the
communications department he graduated
with journalism um
public relations carpentry yeah
listen when you're when you're in
russian you just have to do whatever
but here in california he
he had his journalism
um degree
and so
we always wanted to use our skills for
god and
he had this yearning to
do a documentary um kind of like a
travel log
and not just to travel to co it's the
eiffel tower oh it's this but um to make
it meaningful and purposeful
and we actually did some campus ministry
there in guam university of guam
and they
had this survey where they go around
asking other students if you could ask
god one question what would it be and
we're like that's a really intriguing
thing because
each student also would be like oh man
what would that be
and it was kind of a little lead-in to
okay you want to get on campus we can
talk about it and we had you know
on-campus studies with that
and we wanted to take that further
and go into
uh different countries and so we
organized like um
it was like a mission slash documentary
project we took
supplies from the clinic and we handed
out like
vitamins and things for the kids and we
brought
like little literature and all these
things but then our main focus was to
find people that we could um survey
and catch it on camera and then
have
other folks come and and
share their opinion on what that
question
uh what answer they would give that
question and then to ask um professors
and pastors as well
that's a really good idea in fact i want
to show that that
video right now check this out
[Music]
oh
i can see how even asking people this
question
where we are in our day-to-day lives how
that can open us up to because god has
answered those questions only some of
them right it's in the bible so what's
the question that you have if the
question has been answered in the bible
oh did you know god did answer that
question and show it to them
because i was a japanese girl she's you
know she had goats in her home in japan
the family raising goats
you know so and she was not a christian
so we asked in japan hey she's you know
you you know english pretty good you
know she studied in america
so so do you have any question for god
if you ask god one question what it
would be
and you know what she has
you know why
in your christianity in your religion
you know christ is symbolic of the lamb
you know has a sheep
you know that's what she asked and
to make the story short later she got
baptized she became a christian
not be quite big you know because of the
questions for god but that was a part of
her journey
you know so she came to go on he gave
some bible studies other people gave
bible studies yeah
so
so give us an example of some of the
questions that people have i mean you
you're interviewing people from many
different walks of life many different
faiths what were some of these questions
that they had
well
i
thought um
some of the questions
that were unique were like uh that one
little girl from zimbabwe she asked um
does god have a wife
and some of the
young people would say i don't think god
needs a wife he's got it
what's funny about all
funny about that is is god does have a
wife yes it's the church that's right
it's right yes
and he speaks about it yes and that was
what the pastor actually shared later so
i think it's um really cool
what comes out of
young people's minds and then
we had a lot of
um culturally
different questions so like if you were
going down into south america and those
areas
a lot of them are
the the religion is very rigid
and they were asking questions like do i
really have to go confess in a
confessional my sins or can i
come straight to god and talk to him
and
those type of things you know
um what is the steps that i have to take
to be saved or you know
a lot of things that are on their minds
are like do i really have to do so much
and you know what they're asking yeah
yeah for salvation and it makes sense to
me that god
you know he's got to be merciful right
we got into this mess because one person
or two people i should say ate an apple
right or it wasn't an apple piece of
fruit whatever it was right
that seems like a relatively easy thing
and then now look how difficult it is
for us to be good i mean we literally
can't we struggle with it constantly
every day all the time and it's like god
had to provide an easy way to counter
balance that easy way for you to get
into sin he's offering you an easy way
to get out of it all you need to do is
give it over and turn it to him yeah so
did you ever go back to russia and ask
that question yes i did
kind of very common question well we
didn't ask the
we are some russians
forgot
in russia but we asked russians abroad
and one lady asked
how do i know how can i find the right
person to marry you
that's a good question
yes and another one was asking about
when is the golden age um
when the millennium will be of
peace or something i don't know
he was a little vague on on what it is
all about
but uh when you got into
other areas of the world like um in
africa and
and those types of things a lot of their
questions were just dealing with you
know why is there suffering and i think
a lot of um
the common theme i would say around the
world is uh
you know if god is so good well why is
there such suffering equality
inequalities
and so forth
but
what was interesting also in europe
there was a lot of secular
secular mindsets there and
a lot of skepticism you know about god
and and if he's really there right
why don't you show yourself
yourself you know type of things
yeah we went to sinai peninsula you know
during 2012 egyptian revolution was
still going there
so in fact we had to book the police
escort without police escort he won't be
allowed to go to cement peninsula so we
had like armed you know with a case
police going
you know
protect us you know there was riots at
the gas station
so it was kind of scary in a way so i
was even asking god question you know do
you really want us to go there at that
time you know but he did it was the arab
spring yeah so he did so we went to this
small there was tents in the carpet
so the police put a case right at the
table you know just laying down
you know unattended you know
kind of like okay
so and then
and we ask
you know the
young people you know you know
you know
do you have a question for god they were
evolutionaries
so they were on the square what they
could hear is called tahir square wow
you know and and she was in her talk
with she was saying
i asked you like before the question for
god
were you scared to go you know and
participate in this you know uprising
and revolution
well the only thing i was concerned that
my parents would find out that i went um
else well actually i found my parents
there
they were university professors and
everything wow so those female muslim
ladies you know they ask a question for
god
how god why god allows corrupted leaders
to be in charge you know how he points
it
why you know where is the connection
with the
god and the leaders of the world or
leaders of the country so yes and
another egyptian man
asked questions for god he says i have a
watch it has a manual you know how to
operate i have a car and it has a manual
how to operate the car
that's god has a you know a manual for
my life
so when you were going around traveling
and asking these questions
did you have people with you who are
giving answers or a way to point people
who ask the questions back to the
answers like hey you know at this time
in this place you'll be able to see the
answer to your question
we took their contact info and we said
we'll send them a dvd and later
we asked you know would you like one and
and we sent some dvds back
some responses from some of those people
like about the answers
i wouldn't
go that far but definitely
we we've been in contact with
those people still yeah i think it's
helpful to see the common denominator um
as i traveled around the world as well
um you know and spent time with with
with people in the middle of
wherever
and you realize we're all not that
different you know we have a lot of the
same questions we have a lot of the same
um struggles i mean some more extreme
than others obviously we don't know what
it's like to have pure poverty in this
in this this country like we do in some
of the third world countries but um i
mean there's there's there's a there's a
lot of common ground there with us in
humanity
and the neat thing ab what i really like
about what you guys are doing is is
really asking those questions but it's
like the bible has answers from all
these questions
because originally like we wanted to
have like quest for meaning kind of
worldwide discussion so somebody is
asking questions then we go to public
opinion
what do you think is the answer you know
and like this guy from l.a i don't think
god needs a wife he's okay you know
you know kind of and then we go to you
know pastor or some theologian or
religion professor of religion and and
so what is the answer from the bible
what do you know is any answer in the
bible if god has a wife and he goes to
the book of revelation the bride of
christ
and so on so it's kind of like worldwide
discussion you know it's like you know
not in the threatening wave
and of course
you know we had some
folks like in brazil a little incident
so we found the
guide who spoke english and he was
jewish he had david stark hanging on him
so would you be able to translate you
know from portuguese you know we would
like to ask a question for god
and in the middle of interview the
camera is rolling you know i have
you know mike in front of the young man
and i see the police approaching us
police say federale you know with the
bulletproof jacket you know big man
you know he interrupt the interview like
what's going on you know whatever
happening yes and
and uh translator is explaining me just
asking questions for god just a simple
street interview isn't okay
and
police said
i would like to say something on the
camera is it okay
so okay you you can wait right okay yeah
so return the camera to the policeman
and he says
well
you know i don't have any
questions for god i just
more have a praises i thank god for my
job for my family
for this country you know i just want to
express you know the
thanksgiving and praise to god
so thank you please continue
it's almost it almost sounds like
in a very big way like in a worldwide
scale
you're recreating what happened for you
on those friday nights it's like you
come
you bring your idea they bring their
ideas you have this discussion yes and
through that discussion
there's a growing process that happens
so i think that's really neat and what's
beautiful is that
dimitri like god
heard or saw the desire of your heart as
a little boy and he brought that full
circle as an adult traveling the world
but you went from uh making less than
thirty dollars you know to going to a
foreign land
meeting a bride and being able to
provide for her and then you went to
travel the world some people's dream
like they're holding down jobs and not
even able to afford a vacation but
you're traveling the world can you give
a little insight as to how that's even
possible
just i mean i can say all things are
possible get gathered and they will give
you desire of your heart so never give
up with your dream because it might be
from god
you know it's just
i always wanted to travel too that was
one of my dreams when i was younger
and there's a text in the bible that
says that god will give you the desires
of your heart yes
and so when you submit your your life
and your plans and everything to him
then
it allow it's like it gives him
it's like he can open this treasure box
for you i guess there's a way to
describe it you know he's like okay
here's the gift i want to give you for
you know submitting whereas if i would
have just stayed in the job i was but
i've probably never gone anywhere
well there is a bible verse you know go
into the world and then one man told me
oh you guys took it literally
we went all the way to antarctica and
that is um
the bottom of the world right the ends
of the
[Music]
but what was cool is just you know these
scientists who are so secular so
um
far from the bible were willing to be on
our project and they were willing to
well i don't know if i really believe
god's there but i'll ask a question for
your documentary and what was
interesting is that they all asked the
same question and that was pretty much
what's going to happen to antarctica you
know how what will be the future because
we know as antarctica goes the whole
earth has come going and with this whole
climate
discussion and that's happening in our
world right now
it's really interesting that
scientifically yes it's it's
the world is wearing as an old garment
you know the bible is correct in that
and
it is
our lifestyles and everything that has
contributed to all this happening
and
people outside our faith are recognizing
this and they're showing us you know
antarctica is losing its krill it's um
feed supply of for the penguins and then
on up the chain to the leopard seals and
whales and we we really want to preserve
and we want to keep this place and
we as stewards of of god's creation
have an obligation to share that same
passion as well
um
but we also
have our scientists uh share
what's coming for the future of this
earth right that we will be
the scientists
the scientists are recognizing that in
this graph so to say they're looking at
all the data is if we keep going in this
way this thing's gonna eventually end
right
which the bible really says well it's
it's not going to end until jesus comes
again you know what i mean and so you
know we we look at the data just with a
little bit different of perspective but
it is interesting to me to observe that
they are actually standing up and and
and and looking at what the the
commission was first given to us take
care of this planet these are this is
yours take care of this
and they're feeling that yearning
watching it's our selfishness that's
ruining this planet you know what i mean
like we've over fished this thing
we've we've destroyed it with toxins
that we put into the air whatever you
know and and um
so that's a fascinating thing to observe
i'm sure your ministry was traveling
around the world um asking these
questions getting into contact with
people covet hit and i'm sure that
changed drastically but you're not not
doing ministry anymore so how did you
pivot like how did you
yeah how did you change your ministry to
fit the time we're living in well we
still meet people right so yeah and then
we do a lot of online bible studies yes
and they have questions for god and we
can point hey you're not the first who
asks you know then they would probably
we might point to our experience and
so it brings people together yes each
week there's this uh english as a second
language
zoom that we're doing
and what they do is it's like open
conversations and
we are put into different rooms um and
you talk for like 15 minutes and then
you switch and
and you do this for an hour
and through those conversations since
it's just to open
whatever
they just want to practice their english
we
try to sway the conversation
towards health and then spiritual health
and and all these uh questions start
coming up it's interesting because
just before we left to come here we were
meeting with a couple from turkey
who are in san francisco at the time and
um
they
were wondering what's going on with this
world and we're in this mess that we're
in and how we're going to get out of it
and so we got to have really good
conversations with them there at the
beach and i think
god is opening doors right now
people's minds are are wondering and
confused and we have answers from the
bible that we can give them
amen so do you guys have a question you
would like to ask god yes i'd like to
know if you could have what i mean just
think about the the amount of time that
poor god's got to like deal with when we
get to heaven right if you spend one day
with god and there's
what billions of people maybe they get
up there i mean that's thousands of
years
it would take just to hang out with god
every day
but one question what do you have for
god
i think for me
it wouldn't it wouldn't necessarily be
like
i don't know i think there's a
temptation to ask questions that some of
the answers depend on our own choices
but i think i'd
you know there's the temptation to ask
like
am i going to make it am i going to be
you know am i going to be one of those
ones that you know am i going to be in
heaven
i think it'd be interesting to ask god
that and
what if you didn't get the answer you
wanted
you know
then i would quickly fire back can i
change it
what must i do to have eternal life am i
going the right direction you know in my
life or is there something that is there
something i need to work on or or change
or you know
those kind of questions i i would
probably ask
you know probably about my kids too
i think i have more of a request than a
question like i want to spend a day with
you like because because
just having an understanding of the
great controversy and what god has to
allow for this
fair like due process to happen and how
good things happen to bad people bad
things happen to good people and god is
in the position to do something but
doesn't always do some do that thing
because
of you know how things need to play out
and how all of this all of our decisions
the choice to serve him is a choice and
not doing it out of you know robots or
some kind of law so
there's choice and i just god must be
going through it you know until that end
time when he comes for the second time
so just
but there's that side but also seeing
um the miracles like how he works in
people's lives and the things that he
can do and how people open themselves up
to his power and how he works with them
just spending a day
i'm sure would be just fascinating
so that that question you know about
suffering like why does god allow
suffering and why is there pain in the
world and why doesn't god do something
about that i read an excellent book so
um there's a book called the odyssey of
love by john peckham um
he's a theology professor and you can
get the book on amazon it's only like
you know maybe 10 15
excellent book it really lays that all
out from the bible really well so i'd
recommend that resource and i'm sure we
can probably put that link in the
description below
um another question i have for you guys
is do you have a website
where
you're
if the documentary is on amazon okay the
documentary amazon yeah so they can
search um quests through seven
continents
yeah questions to god there okay
well i think that what you're doing is
awesome and and you know if you guys
have questions one thing that we're
doing at little light is we're trying to
answer those as well we started a new
segment called i've got a question
where you guys can submit your questions
and we will answer them we're probably
going to look for patterns you know the
same question being asked multiple times
and we've also had started working on a
series a while back that we're trying to
get back to called video bible studies
and those are a little bit longer than
i've got a question but
uh really explaining bible truths and
giving answers for that so
i think as christians we have that
responsibility you know to give
answers to people who are are searching
and maybe even awaken
the search in somebody's own heart yeah
i i have one question for god that isn't
necessarily in the bible and i just want
to know being a parent
when jesus was being crucified on the
cross
how did you how did you turn around like
how did you you know everything you know
all these things you're saying your son
is there i think that we often talk
about the suffering of jesus
but god
i mean just as a parent i would gladly
give my life for my child any day so i
want to know like where did you go god
where you know what how how difficult
was that for you and and i'd love to
hear his answer for that
well a more funny question is did
mosquitoes exist in the garden of eden
how are they going to
yeah
not in the same light that we see them
they probably had a good function my
wife wonders if spiders are going to be
in heaven and if they are because their
whole job is to spin a web to catch
something else and eat it right so
what's it going to do in heaven
spin web
[Laughter]
one of my questions are there our pets
who they passed away yeah some of the
you know favorite cats and the dogs
all right thank you
the bible has answers brothers and
sisters and uh thank you guys for coming
by
if you guys have questions trust what
we're saying here you can stand on that
word of god and there is something in
there that literally will answer the
questions that you have
and if you don't know how or where to
start just start like these guys did
lord help me and all of a sudden god
will show up in a mighty way and uh
we've heard testimony after testimony on
this channel of that experience and so
we want that experience to be for you
guys as well if you have a question for
us of course leave it in the comment
section below if you're new to our
channel welcome like and subscribe to us
because we've got a lot of cool content
and uh check out some of our other stuff
and like keith mentioned um check out
some of the the new things that we're
coming up with that i got a question and
uh we're gonna get back on that video
bible study series so we can really get
to the heart of the issue and that's to
build a relationship with jesus
thank you for watching we'll see you
guys next week
[Music]
[Applause]
you